pab une poule à elles sont toutes les
femmes de ta des jours pas plus que nous
papa l'a pas tous louent pas poule au
pot pas pour nous elle est ou m'écrit
partir genre oh [ __ ] de 0,1
il était bien sur la d9 après là j'étais
vachement enfants qui ceci sur le
territoire est plus sûr compte sur la
carte
il faut qu'ils sur la gamme alors
maintenant je vais faire juste des jeux
prime un test mais j'ai tenu parole
c'est que focus sur laquelle ça va pas
mal là ça a l'air pas mal
là ça a l'air pas mal là ça a l'air pas
mal
enfin [ __ ] tu me la mets coulisses 3 0
je veux mais c'est un tout petit peu la
clim tu peux baisser un tout petit peu
la clim tu peux bci un tout petit peu tu
peux baisser un tout petit peu la
campagne a nominé aux avc hd optique qui
menacent la paix si un tout petit peu la
clim
tu peux laisser un tout petit peu tu
peux baisser au tout seul
tu peux
si jamais l'affairé les artistes telles
études et un extincteur a déjà utilisé
de temps des quatre acteurs non visés
tomber car ou leur garou et la chanson
celui qui l'a jamais été
ça fait cinq ans j'ai pas le titre et
j'ai les visages si je décris misé un
seul dvd vêtements ou alors au cachot
qui n'est pas ta ceinture mec c'est une
chance et lui non plus tard hier les
gars je paye tout et après on cale d'un
drap sur le site où on calculera sur
l'eau related paye tout mais je dois te
prends pas la tête paye tout et c'est
tout prend pas la tête mais tous les
cinq ans par tête but mais c'est tout je
prends par la petite porte police et où
barack obama
pour l'atp mais non je pas d'accord
c'est devenu ça te prend pas à la tête
et aux citoyens j'ai reconnu jalousie
parce que je ne prends pas la tête plus
tout aussi à la tête mais tout est bien
la même chose h et de la somme
la ducat manceau il a dû lui avant que
ça tue trois personnes il est le seul à
voir le seul maître gims
jamais il n'a même pas eu neuf il ya des
50 à trouver un interprète
la fnac
bon il ya 5,3
5-5 croirait sa relance
mon nom qui sa part totalement cool
on peut dire moi je crois
dimanche on
on peut dire moche accéléré de
sensualité khanjian 10
[Musique]
et voilà je leur en faire une micro
sieste
mêlant tu conduis lent mais non mais tu
conduis maison de médan du monde numéro
dans la bataille finale
[Musique]
une carte faisait harris et roman table
c'est vrai
sermon table c'est faisable c'est c'est
faisable c'est remonte à trop bon teint
c'est faisable
sûrement la mort c'est faisable
la cesam ses remords intérieur mais oui
il peut mieux faire et remonte à si on
dit que plusieurs partis sur la même île
va repartir sur la même repartir et
c'est par là
doit partir il va pas ressasser les
mêmes
parti il va partir cela même pour
repartir livarot perfectionna partie
ouais c'est une ville de 9,5 par les
cinq secondes politique est là notre
coin ça j'ai pour toi
yes moi je suis aussi très focus sur la
conduite tu voyais astruc ou lafargue et
afro ci après
- suite
très focus
sans la conduite et coûteux
ya ce truc or l'histoire feria
il ya ce truc
je peux faire gaffe après
moi je suis très content invention mais
j'attends moi je veux une finale à neuf
j'ai pas vu son gps
il m'a pas indiqué
ses paris sur gb j'ai pas vu ce gp
j'ai pas vu sans gêner tout sonnait
réhabiliter l'image invités j'ai pas vu
s'user psg pas danger
[Musique]
trois cents à niederentzen 9,8 mon gars
d'être inquiet après ces deux points
d'écart à penser
après ces deux
des cars
yann gilbert montagné 9,9
[Musique]